à l'occasion de la venue dans l'île aux
enfants quelques amis très distingué
monsieur du snob serais très heureux de
vous recevoir chez lui aujourd'hui ça
sera peut être rigolo
ben tu vois rigolo ne me paraît pas être
le mot hexagram tunis nabil très
sympathique mais c'est pas tellement le
genre rigolo ça dépend moi il me fait
rire dès que je le vois je marque je me
moque pas de lui mais je me demande si à
certains moments ils s'amusent pas lui
même à jouer les snobs reparti
c'est peut-être parce qu'il s'appelle
monsieur du snob en tout cas si tous ses
amis sont comme lui ça sera pas très
très drôle
au contraire s'ils sont tous comme lui
ça sera un spectacle très amusant relie
son invitation à l'occasion de la venue
dans l'île aux enfants de quelques amis
très distingué monsieur du snop serais
très heureux de vous recevoir chez lui
aujourd'hui titre en compte quelques
amis à distinguer six ans tous comme lui
ce sera un véritable spectacle lit sur
le seuil est de parler comme eux ce sera
amusant oui c'est une idée formidable va
mon très cher françois vie je vous
serais extrêmement obligé de me exprimer
ce que vous ressentez de vence
shall have de la sculpture molaires
autres mais vous avez trouvé la très
chère julie une véritable merveille
cette sculpture est un authentique chef
d'oeuvre quelle force et et en même
temps quelle finesse l'espadon les
intentions de l'artiste cela je vous là
vous me paraître admirable est votre
jugement tout à fait remarquable et
quand enjeux soudaine mais vous parlez
en verre l'avez vous dites moi cette
expo oui mon cher
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il faut sept îles sont plus nobles comme
ceux du snav
on l'a l'art c'est très inquiétant en
soi un joli hein
est ce que vous êtes parent est anormal
que les ce personnage un peu envahissant
je lis tu vas bien qui vient de me
tutoyer thibault tu te dis que cela est
indécent en vous
or c'est horrible c'est bien ce que je
craignais ils sont fous il faut que je
fasse quelque chose je vais téléphoner
un docteur moi je vais vous donner si
votre ardeur sans tête un coup de
téléphone sur le haut casimir convié
casimir mais non casimir mais arrête de
crier comme ça tu vas arrêter tout ni le
vent ni veau miam des coquelicots mourir
d'un coup de téléphone mais n'ont quasi
mur personne ne songe à tpv n'y sommes
pas fini tout pourquoi ce que vous
m'avez parlé de façon si stupide alors
on s'amusait tu vas comprendre on
regarde ce que monsieur du snob envoyé
pour toi pour moi et pour tous à lille
casimir monsieur kazimierz et aux sétois
réside à l'occasion de la venue dans
l'île aux enfants de quelques amis très
distingué monsieur du snob saurait très
heureux de vous recevoir chez lui
aujourd'hui
et voilà je suis invitée c'est
formidable
il y aura peut-être des sandwichs ont
saucisson à la confiture de groseilles
mois il des sandwichs au saucisson à la
confiture de groseilles cher monsieur du
snop franchement ça m'étonnerait tu vois
tes émis et reçus des snobs un dégoût
originaux ça veut dire le contraire mais
ce sont pas exactement les mêmes que les
tiens ça fait rien rien ne m'empêche de
mélanger du crabe avec du piment et de
mettre ça sur une tarte à la fraise
on devrait peut-être se dépêcher parce
que ça va être alors ça c'est vrai des
raisons est que c'est plutôt table je
vais même pas vendre le tout me faire
une jolie coiffure et pourquoi qu'est ce
que tu veux changer à tes cheveux mais
les défrise ap
tu veux que je tire dessus enfin kg mais
s'il suffisait de tirer sur les cheveux
pour qu'il soit raid il y aurait plus
beaucoup de filles avec les cheveux
frisés n'est ce pas hommage et une autre
idée hein ne bougez pas attendez moi
dépêche-toi a tout de suite casimir dit
d'angélisme je me demande ce qui va
encore bien pouvoir fabriquer je suis un
peu inquiète je t'avoue tout le faire
des prises et les cheveux par casimir
c'est une perspective qui n'est pas
rassurante toute façon tu n'es pas
obligé d'accepter quoi que ce soit et
puis je t'aiderai de défendre haut
excuse moi c'est râpé désolé tu peux
être désolé me faire une peur pareil
kazemi
pour ai dit désolé que ce qui n'a pas
marché dans son plan mais c'était ma
méthode
je voulais lui faire très peur oui
pourquoi ces chauves ou sunrise tour ça
pète est comme ça qu il aura été
maîtrisé a battu ses casimir tu as
vraiment des idées un peu spécial allez
c'est pas grave de toute façon julie je
t'assure comme ça et à cheveux frisés tu
vraiment très bien
oui mais alors il faut que je m'habille
aussi c'est vrai puis moi je veux pas y
aller quand même avec une chemise à
carreaux et c'est impossible chez
monsieur 19 ça doit être très élégant on
va demander aux enfants de nous aider
d'accord moi c'est semble-t-il dit allez
les enfants c'est pour nous aider pour
les besoins de vos salles et nous en
fait miné alors voilà casimir juillet
moi nous sommes invités par monsieur du
snob aller à une soirée très habillée
par an nous avons parfois m vous l'aviez
nous aider christophe on commence par
julie du bifff à ton avis j'y joue des
diamants kurma très bien et après il ya
d'autres idées quoi andré gide en plus
tu peux ajouter quelque chose que
christophe christophe a vu julie
habillée comme ça tu peux la voir
habillée d'une autre façon donne ton
avis montaner pantalon habillé de soir
très bonne idée suivante soit une tape
amicale où j'aimerai pas être couturier
plus tard ça ne ferait pas un je
travaille avec lui tous les deux on voit
les germes quatre rouges bon on passe à
moi mon père je me montre en or il
montre en or
et puis quand même un pantalon noir un
pantalon noir des chaussures noires des
chansons graves un manteau bleu bleu
foncé ni casquette à carreaux gris meech
non non un chapeau noir
r j'aimerais bon et toi jean jacques ces
canadiens ont costil accoster et
couleurs noir et c'est de faire un petit
peu différent de serge la classe et je
choisirai ce dans ma garde-robe à ce que
je peux trouver parce que j'ai pas une
garde-robe l'être toujours un en chemise
à carreaux ou alors on papillon à noeud
papillon très bien de quelle couleur
non annabel lyon blanc et chaussettes un
chapeau d'une vrai qu'un chapeau ali à
chapeau commun ba écoute comme ça je
pense que je m'en tirer dans le ballon
passe à casimir est bon pour moi
qu'est ce que tu crois que tu mettrais à
casimir pour aller en soirée chez
monsieur du snob allons réussir
howell et chaussures vertes non les
choses horaires de grosses chaussures
fétiches vernis à ongles par berthe
berlinois et puis réjane est-ce que tu
as une idée un jeune je vous
une chemise à carreaux cassés oui
peut-être parce que je lui mettrais un
chapeau ou une casquette noire
on croyait que s'est rhabillé ça bon
lionel a plutôt une chemise noire une
chemise moi oui cela tranchera avec
sarah quelques la c3 compte quasi
mythique j'en ai des idées là alors
simulé par très élégant je me suis snob
c'est impardonnable écoutait jetable au
[Musique]
bond et un pantalon noir
bon maintenant allant chacun chez soi
pour voir si nous allons trouver quoi
m'habiller maisons sont heureux
[Musique]
bah
ouh là là didon gênés ou comme des
élégantes seb a savouré et au site est
très sucré orelsan ouais mais c'est
quand je me suis regardé dans la glace
comme ça chez moi j'ai vraiment eu du
mal à me reconnaît qu'est ce que ça
change
mais voilà kazimiya c'est tout ce que tu
as trouvé peut-être dans saint casimir
tu aurais pu mettre un beau costume
quand même bon vous savez moi un rien
l'habille qassimi bon bah écoutez il
faut se mettre en route maintenant
allons-y
mais quid la part de chez les jeunes
hommes à merci très chère julie
juste un mot pour vous préciser à tous
les trois qu'il s'agit d'une soirée très
décontracté au bord de la piscine
venez dans vos habits de tous les jours
et surtout n'oubliez pas vos maillots
[Musique]